foreign leading the capitals against the Detroit
Red Wings in the first of a home and home set on
Ice officials referees are Chris Rooney and Mike
Sullivan 80 seconds in the man Advantage you know
Hanson crowded by kuznetsov Nick Michael out
there in the penalty killing posture as well
for Washington 24 in the red snapshot deflected
there Lindgren was at the top of the gold
crease confer cradles work at defabry seen pass
Lindgren a sprawling stop there an outstanding
save for Charlie Lindgren forced it back to
the point Carlson will switch it for Ovechkin
snap wide rotation for roshi again he
has room on his back in he hit the post
TJ oshie's arguably one of the best hands
guys below the bottom of the circle changing
their penalty Killers On The Go as you
watch sandeen Cruise back through Center
Wilson on the plane McMichael splits the Gap
to the backhand lion made the pad sane now
marosh nachenko will drop it off on an octel
through Center didn't connect with McMichael
invested on a breakaway just a few moments
ago strong nice centering pass great Club
save Lindgren with the denial on JT comfort for
first period that line at the other end right
in control there trying to sip that puck over the
right pad the splits the answer there to the catch
so excited I've done so many alumni events and
we got these beautiful jackets like you're gonna
upset Joe because he hasn't got his yet you're
not upsetting me I never wore the blades for the
cats well Wilson right on in and an early stick
save for Lyon in The Games first 10 seconds of
the second period capitals buzzing around the
Detroit net well that's a good guy to play
with it was amazing who else uh well I mean play
with gretz obviously in Los Angeles which was an
amazing time good glove save there Lindgren with
the denial on Marco Casper I played with Luke two
exactly play with him in L.A he was a great guy
good catching glove save there goaltending this
day and age I don't know if I'd score a whole lot
three and a half minutes into the second still no
score for Washington and Detroit Edmondson on a
slap pass down low strong turns and scores Daniel
strong and a little turnover and Daniel strong
makes the Caps pay that's tremendous patience
and to me that's just confidence coming off
the year that he had the Caps he had 21 goals
but this is the goal scorers goal picks it up
on his skate and then Waits out the goaltender
to put her in Jerusalem I mean patience is so
important when you get in tight it's really
hard to control that and be patient especially
with the second effort of the goaltender sliding
across the creek but you can see that he's waiting
waiting then gets the release away 12 and a half
did at the offensive end of the Ring Backstrom
plays it around for Ovechkin Ovechkin to the front
Backstrom steers it home Nicholas Backstrom
on the redirect yeah gets away from the big
screen in front of the net and bits and just got
his stick on it enough but here it is down low
Backstrom finds open ice and just sort of chops
at it so it gets away from the defender's stick
the push-up OB will get the primary assist the
ramp up the Ricochet and Backstrom has tied it
here in the second period we get a second and
third look at it it may have finally deflected
in off of Edmondson too yeah either way it's
foiled lion lifted at five foot ten right off
the draw bang to the corner Tom Wilson and evgeny
kuznetsova wow what a shot that was ovechkiness by
Tom Wilson our play but he also worked Face-Off
plays and it doesn't get any more beautiful than
that the instant shot the win of the drawback is
next top the good formation the little pit there
moving to the net would Rafferty little give and
go at Point position bumping on around Johannes
Stevens to the slot area Lindgren paddle down
with a denial on Dominic shine fabric taken to
the board by John Carlson if only fabric
can stay healthy three times on his knee
ACL reconstruction if he's healthy
he's a Difference Maker closing in
bathroom Backstrom Ovechkin and marosh nachenko
buzzing here for the capital Carlton has plenty
of room to get downhill feeds it to Sandy
sandeen riffs one in arosh nacheco put it
off the outside of the cave Ovechkin all the
way through Carlson same scene well that's
good fires that's tucked away [Applause] future
caps alumni or future uh cats learned to play
yeah a wonderful program that we've got going
on winding it back up sandeen through Senate
connecting with McMichael looking
out wide for Wilson Mata is there
Crystal plays to the point sandeen closes long
Richter score [Applause] second wave of the
power play jumps on the ice they get it back
to sandeen an innocent looking wrister right
taking away the eyes Conor McMichael working the
front of the net to sort of have an eye formation
set up there with McMichael and Wilson in the
high side there's Wilson there's Michael real
good job all around right that's the type of
looks he needs to score on right no question
you know and with our alumni oh it looks like
it went off maybe the photo Wilson there maybe
oh she on the go PJ one on one had it blocked
Crystal closing nice pass for Oshi one touched
it down and a sprawling save by Cosa things happen
in the draft here's that downplay getting around
bad boy throwing around him and throwing it
at the net look at that pad coming across
there good overhead look at Cosa and it's
22 year old Albert Johansson will take back
anisima failed to clear ing B to the front
Carson scores John Carlton barrows hit Tango
what a play in front of the neck this was
after an extended shift and they still had
the wherewithal to continue so a late step kept
their legs going there's the pass in the shot
enko will get his second helper this hockey
game as he sets up John Carlson he's had a
wheel of a hockey game here tonight should
be the first star of the way he's played that
whole line has been terrific Carlson finishes
it off sandeen and Carlson with 320 left yeah
it works for both plays not only the caps
and Detroit practice this situation here
and the practice shootout to come once we are
through with regulation time here in Capital One
Red Wings attacking seeing fabri fires he scores
fabry with a dart upstairs at seven goals but
watch his pass by Daniel strong through scarbosa
through the other side found that lane in the slot
the D didn't step up in time Johansson looking
for an Evanston wrister stop there by Lindgren
the rebound bounce to the corner confer relays
Edmondson and fabry in tight quarters Edison
closing lets it go off the shoulder of Lindgren
rebound there for the Caps to the glass and now
ocean will advance TJ has the empty net waiting
he hit the post clean Coston sends in fabric
tiptoes around one Defender matched up there by
Johansson with 80 Seconds to play Michael crowded
by valeno because Nets off didn't get it out and
there's favery firing another one home yeah Far
Side fabri finds that loose Puck with 73 seconds
left and puts it far aside good legs good hockey
sets here he gets the buck Liberty gets it and
snaps it notice kuznetsov tried to chip it away
from him doesn't get past the end of his stick
right here he gets a piece but not enough and a
knuckle Puck eludes Charlie underneath this glove
hits the bottom of the glove and it's 4-3 confer
against kuznetsov you see this Face-Off numbers
for those two pivot men this is a stalemate kicked
Loose by beleno short side shut down by Lindgren
and the horn Washington hangs on for the win